Transcriptor: Nora Quiroz
Revisor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
(Aplausos)
28 kilogramos.
Cualquier decisión que yo tomaba cuando
tenía 11 años giraba entorno a este número
Decisiones en cuanto a elegir si ponerle
pasta de dientes a mi cepillo o no,
porque me asustaba el número de
calorías que esta podría contener.
Esconder comida en jarrones,
cajones, en mis bolsillos,
incluso detrás de mi cabello,
con tal de que las calorías
no pasarán por mi garganta.
Cuando piensan en desórdenes alimenticios,
¿qué es lo primero que se
les viene a la cabeza?.
Puede que hayan pensado en una mujer
que es extremadamente flaca
y que decide dejar de comer para poder
lucir como las modelos en una revista.
Pero la realidad es muy diferente
y por eso hoy estoy aquí,
para poder platicarles la verdadera
cara de estas enfermedades
porque no son una moda del siglo XXI,
como muchos lo podrían pensar,
y tampoco son un estilo de vida;
¡son una enfermedad!.
¡Son un suicidio!
De chiquita, tenía un concepto bastante
equivocado sobre lo que es
y cómo se consigue la aceptación propia.
La primera vez que me
sentí fea tenía 5 años.
Y creo que aquí nos tenemos que
estar preguntando como sociedad,
¿qué es lo que estamos haciendo para
que este tipo de pensamientos
estén en la cabecita de una
niña de cinco años?
Porque este es mi caso personal,
pero hay muchas personas allá afuera
que se sienten como yo me sentía antes.
Una de las preguntas que más pasaba
por mi cabeza era: ¿qué se siente?
¿Qué se siente ser bonita?
¿Qué se siente verse bonita?
¿Qué se siente sentirse bonita?
¿Qué se siente verse en un espejo
y no odiar lo que estás viendo?.
Intentar responder estas preguntas
e intentar encajar con las respuestas,
lo único que provocó fue que
a mis once años casi pierdo la vida.
Hasta la fecha creo que no hay
respuestas para estas preguntas
y me parece completamente absurdo
intentar meter a una caja,
a un concepto, a una imagen,
a una idea lo que es la belleza.
No sé explicarte lo que es,
pero puedo decirte lo que no es.
Y puedo decirte lo que me habría
gustado saber cuando era una niña.
Antes de que la frase “me siento gorda”
se clavará en mi cabeza
como una daga que terminaría con
mi autoestima y casi con mi vida.
Si el sabor de la belleza son
noches incomodas sin dormir
porque tus huesos se encajan
en el colchón de tu cama,
perder la mitad de tu cabello,
tener frío todo el tiempo.
¿Cuándo se volvió normal
que una niña de once años
se desvele por estar planificando
lo que va a comer al día siguiente?
¿o por estar contando calorías?.
Y me da muchísimo miedo hablar
de este tema en público
porque es un tema que tiene
bastantes prejuicios:
“seguramente, lo hace para
llamar la atención”
“¡Ay! Déjala, está jugando a tirarse
para que la levanten”
“Dice que se siente gorda y fea porque
le encanta que le digan lo contrario
y que es la más guapa de la fiesta”
Todas estas son respuestas
que he escuchado
cuando alguien decide abrirse
por completo y plática
lo que realmente piensa sobre sí mismo.
Cuando en realidad
no sabemos qué es lo que le muestra
el espejo a la otra persona,
y tampoco sabemos cómo es que su
cerebro interpreta la realidad.
Estas enfermedades lo que hacen es que
te separan por completo de la realidad.
Lo que ves en el espejo
está distorsionado,
porque esta es la forma en
la que tu cerebro funciona.
Entonces, si una persona que
padece de un desorden alimenticio
te dice que se siente gordo o gorda,
no es porque quiera llamar la atención
o porque está jugando a
“tirarse para que lo levanten”.
Es porque literalmente esto
es lo que ve en el espejo.
Como que se tiene esta idea
de que las personas
que padecen de desórdenes
alimenticios es gente vanidosa
que debería enfocarse en otra cosa
y no solamente en su apariencia física.
Que la enfermedad seguramente surge
por idolatrar cuerpos de modelos.
Que es un requisito tener que estar
extremadamente bajo peso
para poder padecer una de estas
enfermedades, cuando en realidad,
tu peso no determina la
gravedad de la enfermedad
porque el trastorno es mental y no físico
y la pérdida de peso es
solamente una consecuencia
de lo que pasa dentro de tu cabeza,
pero no es la causa o un parámetro para
poder decidir si alguien está enfermo o no
Por ejemplo: ¿alguna vez le has llamado
a alguien anoréxica o anoréxico
solamente porque es más
delgado de lo normal?.
Este tipo de comentarios lo único que
hacen es contribuir a esta idea de pensar
que para poder padecer de un trastorno
de la alimentación tienes que
estar extremadamente bajo peso
pero las cosas no tienen
por qué ser así y no son así.
De hecho, contrario a la creencia popular,
los desórdenes alimenticios tienen mucho
más que ver con querer tener el control
que con el hecho de querer bajar de peso.
Hay estudios científicos que demuestran
que hay cierto tipo de individuo
a nivel genético que al ser sometidos
bajo situaciones de estrés
son capaces de desarrollar
una de estas enfermedades.
¿A qué voy con esto?
Más que las causas sean sociales
como muchos lo podrían pensar
también son biológicas y genéticas,
y digo que tienen que ver con control
porque estas enfermedades te hacen creer
que al tú poder controlar lo que comes
vas a poder controlar lo que sientes.
Entonces, cualquier preocupación
que este pasando en tu vida
va a ser bloqueada por este pensamiento.
Como mecanismo de defensa,
tu cerebro crea otra realidad
en la que tus únicas preocupaciones
son el peso y la comida.
Porque estas son cosas que
tú puedes controlar,
y sin embargo allá afuera,
en tu vida real
hay cosas que tú no controlas.
Después de varias sesiones de terapia
me di cuenta de que prefería sentir
hambre a tener que sentir
y enfrentar el dolor que otras situaciones
podrían estar causando en mi vida.
Y esto es lo duro de estas enfermedades;
que te hacen creer que tú estás en control
cuando en realidad quien
te ha estado controlando
todo el tiempo es la enfermedad.
Y creo que aquí, la pregunta
que puede surgir es ¿por qué?
¿Por qué elegir dejar de comer
hasta llegar al borde la muerte?.
Y la pregunta es muy dura,
pero la respuesta es bien sencilla:
¡No es una decisión!.
Los desórdenes alimenticios no se eligen,
pero recuperarse de ellos sí lo es.
Si alguien pudiera preguntarme:
¿qué es la anorexia?
Yo diría que es un monstruo que se
alimenta de la inseguridad humana.
Y quiero evitar que ese monstruo
llegue a la vida de más personas.
Cada vez deseamos que haya más.
Más perfección.
Más delgadez.
Más tonificación.
Y sin darnos cuenta, todos estos "más"
nos han llevado a que cada vez
sean más las chiquitas
que tienen miedo a engordar.
A que cada vez sean más las mujeres
que se someten a cirugías estéticas.
A que cada vez sean más las personas
que desarrollan desórdenes alimenticios.
A que cada vez sean más las incomodidades
y sacrificios que estamos dispuestos
a aguantar solamente porque a alguien
se le ocurrió decir que eso es belleza.
¿No será que entre tantos “más”
solamente nos estamos haciendo menos?
Porque también ahí estamos...
deseando que cada vez haya menos.
Menos grasa, menos calorías,
menos estrías, menos celulitis,
menos arrugas, menos canas, menos granos.
¿No será que por querer encajar tanto
y mantener este personaje falso,
irreal e inalcanzable,
solamente nos estamos haciendo
menos a nosotros mismos?.
Perdiendo nuestra esencia
y quién realmente somos.
Porque seguro, el número en
la balanza comienza a disminuir,
pero también el número de sonrisas que
tendrás, el número de años que vas a vivir
y el número de veces que realmente
te vas a sentir pleno y vivo.
En lugar de sumar, te estás restando.
En lugar de ser más, te haces menos:
menos feliz, menos seguro, menos tú.
Yo te lo quiero preguntar:
¿es ese el sabor de la belleza?
¿Un estómago vacío, mareos, dolor de
cabeza, puntos de cirugías estéticas?
¿Qué tanto le tenemos que
restar a nuestro cuerpo
para poder sentirnos conformes
con nosotros mismos?
Si alguien me hubiera dicho que esta
idea que se me metió a la cabeza
de creer que al alcanzar el peso perfecto
iba a ser feliz, era una completa mentira;
me habría enfocado mucho más
en disfrutar a mi familia, mis amigas,
hubiera jugado más con mis muñecas.
En lugar de haber pasado parte de mi
infancia; encerrada, contando calorías,
torturándome a mí misma por
no encajar en mis expectativas.
Porque así se me fueron tres
años de mi vida.
Viviendo de meta en meta.
Esperando el día en el que
la pluma de la balanza
marcará el peso perfecto para así
poder aceptarme a mí misma.
Pero esto nunca pasó,
y nunca pasó
porque estaba intentando tapar
vacíos con cosas externas.
Y creo que como humanos estamos
bien atorados en eso.
Creemos que no vamos a ser felices
hasta que consigamos tal trabajo,
cierto nivel de vida, cuando
te vayas a vivir a no se dónde,
cuando bajes solamente dos kilos más
y es cuando mágicamente te vas
a sentir cómodo contigo mismo.
¿No te das cuenta de que
estas son puras mentiras?.
Hay una frase que me encanta
de Jim Carrey que dice que
él desearía que todo el mundo
fuera rico y famoso
y cumpliera todos sus sueños
para que se diera cuenta de
que esa no es la solución.
Y me encantó porque, aunque
yo no soy Jim Carrey,
ni me he hecho así de famosa,
ni he ganado el dinero que él tiene
ni me estoy comparando y tampoco creo
necesarios tener que llegar a ese nivel;
sí pude sentir eso de esa frase
cuando cumplí mis metas
o las cosas que según yo,
me iban a dar felicidad
y curiosamente, cuando las cumplí,
me sentía todavía más vacía.
Y además todo era igual.
Nada más pesaba menos de
la mitad de lo que hacía antes,
tenía un espacio entre mis piernas
mejor conocido como “thigh gap”
y había más gente que me volteaba a ver,
pero todo era igual.
Y cómo yo iba a estar equivocada,
si estaba convencida de que
la felicidad la iba a alcanzar
cuando tuviera el peso perfecto.
Y esta idea me comió tanto la cabeza,
que no solamente terminé por perder kilos,
sino que casi pierdo la vida.
Y creo que todos, en cierto grado,
hemos vivido lo mismo.
Ponlo en el tamaño que quieras.
Te imaginabas con tu nuevo celular
y ya que lo tienes te da igual,
empiezas a perseguir otra cosa.
O te imaginabas con tu peinado
y tu maquillaje y tu vestido para
la boda de tu tío fulanito,
y ese día, te da igual.
Estas igual de frustrado, enojado,
lloraste por lo mismo que llorabas antes
y te pasa lo mismo.
No vas a ser más feliz con todo lo que
se te ocurre que está en el futuro,
ni vas a ser más feliz si recuperarás
todo lo del pasado.
Renuncia a eso que crees que está
en el futuro y renuncia a lo que fuiste
y vive y disfruta del aquí y del ahora,
y acéptate en tu totalidad
como estás ahorita.
Creo que el momento presente es
el concepto más subestimado de la realidad
y es el concepto que más
valor nos puede aportar.
El disfrutar del aquí y del ahora hace que
te prendas, te conectes, te da vida,
te da felicidad y te hace entender
qué haces aquí,
pero se nos va de las manos,
porque vivimos creyendo que el
disfrute ya estuvo en el pasado
o va a estar en algún lugar del futuro.
Y así se te va la vida, de meta en meta.
Sin darte cuenta de que tu vida
está pasando ahorita.
Yo ya he renunciado a varias cosas
que creía que quería,
y ha sido uno de los temas que más
me ha costado trabajo.
¿Y si nunca llego a pesar “x” cantidad?.
O si llego a pesar “x” cantidad,
¿pero aun así no es suficiente?.
¡Que liberador! Sería poder
decirme a mí misma...
¿Sabes qué Victoria?,
como que estás medio mensa,
no vas a llegar nunca a ser
lo suficientemente bonita o delgada,
creo que ya no la hiciste.
Júzgueme el que quiera
y alejarse el que se quiera alejar,
pero prefiero eso a tener que estar
cargando con todas esas presiones.
Y me imaginaba, y me imaginaba,
qué liberador sería poder
renunciar a esa estúpida meta,
hasta que un día logré hacer
las paces y decir:
“Ya Victoria, no pasa nada.
Si no cumples ciertas cosas no pasa nada”.
Y ha sido uno de los debates más duros
que he tenido en mi cabeza
porque entonces llegan otras creencias:
“¿Será que me rindo muy fácil?.
¿Será que soy mediocre?”
Y seguramente va a haber alguien
que me este escuchando
que no este de acuerdo conmigo,
la verdad me tiene muy sin cuidado
pero es lo que yo hice en mi cabeza
para estar mejor y apreciar mi vida.
Y eso no quiso decir que
dejé de ir por lo que quería.
De hecho, fue ahí cuando entendí
que no vine al planeta a pesar platos
de comida o a bajar de peso.
Fue ahí también cuando descubrí
cuál era mi verdadero propósito,
y ha sido cuando más ganas,
energía, vitalidad,
transparencias y sonrisas he tenido.
Y es que cuando leí esta frase
de Jim Carrey dije: "Claro.
Es que si todo el mundo pudiera llegar
a eso que cree que lo va a hacer feliz,
de verdad que cómo se lo desearía."
Todos, 7 billones de humanos.
Todos viviendo nuestros sueños
y les puedo firmar que al mes estaríamos
partiéndonos las caras de nuevo
porque no encontraríamos la razón
por la cual sentirnos plenos.
Qué porque el de al lado tiene más,
qué porque ahora quieres otra cosa,
que porque ya conseguiste algo,
pero todavía no es suficiente.
Y ya estaríamos frustrados
con otra tontería,
en miedo con otra tontería y
preocupados por otra tontería.
Y volteo a ver a Jim Carrey y digo:
“A ver, es que si este hombre,
llegó a la luna y yo apenas
le llegue por ahí a una montaña
y sentí exactamente lo mismo que él,
¿para qué le recorro más tiempo? .
¿Por qué no creerle?"
Y es que cuando yo renuncié,
juraba que parte de lo que
me hacía feliz era ir por mis metas,
porque tienes un motor
y tienes un propósito,
pero cuando te encuentras muy
frustrado con ansiedad, depresión
o cualquier emoción que se te venga
a la cabeza que no sea expansiva,
pregúntate: ¿Como para qué fregados
estoy persiguiendo eso?
Y no es que, no es que esté en contra de
tener metas, propósitos o sueños,
¡todo lo contrario!.
Pero es saber poder distinguir
si lo que quieres alcanzar
lo quieres tener para llenar vacíos o
lo estás haciendo por amor,
porque ahí es en donde
cambia todo el panorama.
Y puede que estés diciendo:
"Va, pero ¿cómo?,
¿cómo suelto?".
Perdónate y renuncia a eso
que crees que te va a hacer feliz.
Y, ¿por qué digo perdónate?
Porque créeme que es un proceso bien duro
por todo lo que socialmente cargamos.
Porque tanto me lo dije,
tanto me convenció mi cabeza
de que había que conseguir eso.
Tanto hice, tanto sacrifiqué,
tanto aguanté
qué pensar que ya no
o que podría ya no tenerlo; duele.
Como que te sientes un perdedor,
y hablando de eso,
la frase: “los ganadores no renuncian”.
Al contrario, qué perdedora me he sentido
yo cuando estaba persiguiendo todo eso
que creía que me iba a hacer feliz,
y ni siquiera me sentía plena
Qué perdedora me he sentido yo
cuando lo tenía todo
y yo estaba suicidándome.
Y al contrario: ¡Qué ganadora!,
qué maravilla poder disfrutar
del aquí y del ahora
y ser de verdad plena y agradecerlo.
Hazte un favor y mírate a ti mismo
Pero no solamente te veas, ¡mírate!.
Déjame ser tu espejo
porque eres mucho más
que un número en la balanza,
el tamaño de tu casa
o cualquier meta retorcida que
sea que estés persiguiendo.
Durante tanto tiempo,
estuve deseando cambiar mi físico
para así poder aceptarme a mí misma,
sin darme cuenta de que lo que tenía
que cambiar era mi mentalidad.
Durante tanto tiempo estuve
deseando ocupar menos espacio
y ahora no me importa ocupar más de él.
¡Hoy mi energía llena todo el auditorio!
Muchísimas gracias por haberme escuchado.
(Aplausos)